Durante los últimos cinco años, la regla
de oro de la Inteligencia Artificial ha
sido simple y brutal: "Si quieres una
IA más inteligente, hazla más grande".
Más parámetros. Más GPUs. Más
miles de millones de dólares.
Y funcionó... hasta ahora.
Pero entonces, nos golpeamos contra un muro.
Los modelos se han vuelto tan monstruosamente
grandes que ejecutarlos cuesta más que la
electricidad de una ciudad pequeña. Estamos
quemando el planeta para que un chatbot nos
diga la capital de Francia. Es insostenible.
La industria intentó arreglarlo con trucos como
la "Mezcla de Expertos" (MoE), encendiendo solo
partes del cerebro a la vez. Fue un buen parche.
Sin embargo, DeepSeek —la empresa china que tiene
a Silicon Valley sudando frío— acaba de decir:
"Eso no es suficiente. Todavía
están haciendo algo estúpido".
Acaban de publicar un paper revolucionario
junto con la Universidad de Pekín.
Presentan algo llamado "Engram".
Y no es solo una mejora. Es una acusación.
DeepSeek dice que incluso GPT-5
y Claude 3 son, fundamentalmente,
"amnésicos". Cada vez que ven una palabra, la
vuelven a aprender desde cero. Gastan energía
recalculando lo que ya deberían saber.
"Engram" cambia eso. Le da a la IA
algo que los humanos damos por
sentado: Memoria Real Instantánea.
Hoy vamos a desglosar este paper. Vamos a ver
por qué esto no solo hace a la IA más rápida,
sino que, contra todo pronóstico, la hace
más inteligente en matemáticas y código.
Si tienes acciones en NVIDIA, si eres ingeniero,
o si simplemente quieres saber cómo será la IA de
2026, quédate. Porque DeepSeek acaba
de reescribir las reglas del juego.
Para entender por qué Engram es
tan disruptivo, primero tienes
que entender lo increíblemente estúpidos que
son los modelos actuales en cierto sentido.
Imagina esto: Estás leyendo un libro
y ves el nombre "Alejandro Magno".
Tu cerebro no se detiene a calcular: "Mmm...
A-l-e-j-a-n-d-r-o... Nombre masculino...
Origen griego... Conquistador...".
¡No! Tu cerebro hace un "clic".
Instante. Pop. Sabes quién es. Es un
acceso directo mental. Es memoria.
Ahora, mira cómo lo hace una IA tradicional.
Aunque haya visto "Alejandro Magno" mil
millones de veces durante su entrenamiento,
cuando ve esas palabras hoy, recalcula su
significado desde cero. Ejecuta millones de
operaciones matemáticas a través de docenas
de capas neuronales solo para llegar a la
conclusión que ya sabía hace cinco segundos.
Es como tener un amigo que, cada vez
que le mencionas a "Messi", tiene que
ir a Wikipedia a leer su biografía
para recordar que juega al fútbol.
Por lo tanto, estamos desperdiciando una
cantidad obscena de cómputo en lo obvio.
El internet está lleno de cosas
repetidas: "Estados Unidos",
"Por cierto", "Nueva York". Frases
hechas. Nombres. Datos estáticos.
DeepSeek se hizo la pregunta del millón:
"¿Por qué estamos usando supercomputadoras
para procesar frases que deberían ser
un simple 'copiar y pegar' mental?".
Aquí es donde entra la filosofía de Engram: Dejar
que el cerebro deje de perder el tiempo en lo
básico para que pueda concentrarse en lo difícil.
Entonces, ¿qué es exactamente "Engram"?
En términos simples, es un módulo de memoria
rápida que se le injerta al cerebro de la IA.
DeepSeek miró al pasado, a la "vieja escuela" de
la IA, antes de que los Transformers se comieran
el mundo. Recuperaron el concepto de N-gramas.
Un N-grama es simplemente una secuencia común
de palabras. "Reino Unido" es un
bigrama (dos palabras). "El Señor de
los Anillos" es un N-grama más largo.
La idea brillante de DeepSeek fue:
En lugar de obligar a la IA a calcular el
significado de estos patrones capa por capa,
vamos a construir una Tabla de Atajos.
Cuando el modelo ve "Princesa de Gales",
en lugar de pensar, activa el módulo Engram. Este
módulo dice: "¡Alto! Conozco esto. No calcules
nada. Aquí tienes el significado pre-empaquetado".
Le entrega al cerebro principal una "incrustación"
(embedding) lista para usar.
Es como si el modelo tuviera
una "chuleta" o un "machete" en un
examen. No necesita resolver la ecuación
porque ya tiene la respuesta escrita en la mano.
Pero aquí viene la magia de la ingeniería: ¿Cómo
almacenas todas las frases posibles del universo
sin que la memoria sea más lenta que el cálculo?
Aquí es donde los ingenieros
de software van a sonreír.
DeepSeek utiliza un sistema de Hashing.
Imagina que tienes un almacén con mil millones
de estanterías. Normalmente, buscar algo allí
tomaría horas. Pero con Hashing, cada frase tiene
un número de estantería asignado matemáticamente.
Si la IA ve "Inteligencia Artificial",
sabe instantáneamente: "Eso está en el pasillo
4, estante 20, caja 5". Va directo allí.
En el paper, llaman a esto
Búsqueda de Tiempo Constante O(1).
Esto es crucial. Significa que no importa cuán
grande sea la memoria. Puedes tener 10 gigabytes
de memoria o 100 terabytes de memoria.
El tiempo que tarda la IA en encontrar
el dato es exactamente el mismo.
Por lo tanto, DeepSeek ha creado
una forma de escalar la "sabiduría" de la IA
infinitamente sin hacer que la IA sea más lenta.
Rompieron la relación lineal
entre tamaño y latencia.
Y no lo probaron en un modelo de juguete.
Lo entrenaron con 262 billones de tokens.
Para que te hagas una idea, eso es como alimentar
a la IA con una gran parte de toda la civilización
digital humana. Usaron el mismo vocabulario
masivo de DeepSeek V3 (128,000 tokens).
Esto no es teoría. Es una bestia
industrial lista para producción.
Pero espera. Hay un problema obvio aquí.
La memoria es tonta. A veces, "Banco" significa
una institución financiera, y a veces significa
un asiento en el parque. Si la memoria escupe el
significado equivocado, la IA dirá tonterías.
Pero entonces, DeepSeek añadió una
pieza maestra: La Puerta (The Gate).
La IA no confía ciegamente en la memoria
Engram. Tiene un mecanismo interno, un pequeño
detector de verdad, que verifica el contexto.
Cuando la memoria le ofrece un
dato, el cerebro principal pregunta:
"¿Esto encaja con lo que estoy hablando?".
Si encaja, la puerta se abre (valor 1). Si no
encaja o es ruido, la puerta se cierra (valor
0). Es un filtro de calidad en tiempo real.
Ahora, la gran pregunta de ingeniería: ¿Cuánto
cerebro deberíamos reemplazar con memoria?
Porque la memoria ocupa espacio. Los parámetros
ocupan espacio. Es un juego de suma cero.
DeepSeek formalizó esto matemáticamente
y encontró el "Punto Dulce".
Descubrieron que si le das a la IA
demasiada memoria y poco cerebro,
se vuelve tonta para pensar. Si le das mucho
cerebro y poca memoria, es ineficiente.
El equilibrio perfecto es dedicar entre el
20% y el 25% de los parámetros dispersos del
modelo exclusivamente a la memoria Engram.
Esto es una guía de arquitectura para toda
la industria. No es "hazlo todo
memoria". Es "haz que un cuarto
de tu mente sea una biblioteca instantánea".
"Pero espera", dirán los escépticos. "Buscar
en una base de datos gigante es lento.
Esto va a matar la velocidad del chat".
DeepSeek responde con ingeniería de sistemas pura.
Demostraron que pueden alojar esta memoria masiva
fuera de la GPU. Pueden ponerla en la
memoria RAM de la CPU (que es barata y
abundante) y no en la memoria VRAM de la GPU
(que es carísima y escasa, gracias NVIDIA).
Como el sistema es "determinista" (sabe qué
memoria va a necesitar antes de llegar a ella),
hace Prefetching. Pide los datos con antelación.
El resultado: El impacto en la
velocidad es casi nulo.
Un modelo denso pasó de 6,300
tokens por segundo a 6,100. Una caída del 2.8%.
A cambio de una caída imperceptible de velocidad,
obtienes una IA drásticamente más
inteligente, con memoria casi infinita,
que corre en hardware más barato.
Esto es una pesadilla para los vendedores
de GPUs de ultra-alta gama. Demuestra que con
ingeniería inteligente, no necesitas fuerza bruta.
Así que, ¿qué significa esto para el futuro?
Significa que DeepSeek V4 probablemente
ya está usando esto. Significa que la
próxima generación de modelos no serán
solo "cerebros en frascos" aislados, sino
cerebros conectados a bibliotecas vivas.
Engram es la prueba de que no hemos
llegado al límite de la IA. Solo hemos
llegado al límite de la fuerza bruta.
Ahora empieza la era de la elegancia.
Estamos viendo el nacimiento de la "Memoria
Condicional". Una IA que recuerda como nosotros,
piensa más profundo porque no pierde tiempo en
lo básico, y escala sin arruinar la economía.
La pregunta que te dejo es: Si DeepSeek
está regalando esta investigación al mundo
(porque es open source)... ¿qué es lo que tienen
guardado en secreto que no nos están mostrando?
Si valoras entender la tecnología real detrás
del hype, suscríbete. Aquí no leemos notas
de prensa, leemos los papers.
Nos vemos en el próximo avance.